Gelatine - ein billiges Abfallprodukt der
Fleischindustrie. Für viele ein No-Go.
Die Industrie liebt's und nutzt es,
wo sie nur kann.
Unter anderem in unserem Frischkäse,
aber wieso eigentlich?
Und darf das überhaupt noch als
Frischkäse verkauft werden?
Wie die Industrie mit Gelatine trickst,
zeigt Sebastian Lege.
Wer tricksen will, muss das Original
kennen. Für Sebastian geht's auf den Hof
von Käserin Hilde Schiller.
Sie macht ihren Frischkäse ganz
traditionell, braucht also nur Milch,
Starterkultur und einen Tag Zeit.
Mehr nicht!
SEBASTIAN: "Kann man das jetzt so probieren?"
HILDE: "Ja, klar!" - "Ok!"
"Riecht richtig gut!"
"Mhh, sahnig, frisch, leichte Säure. Was will man mehr? Träumchen!"
Gar nicht schlecht. Dauert aber zu lange!
Sebastian hat einen Trick.
SEBASTIAN: "Ich werde gleich eine Variante machen,
wo ich aus wenig Frischkäse ganz
viel Frischkäse mache.
Mit dem ein oder anderen Trick
und ich dadurch auch noch
einen anderen Preis erzielen kann."
Für Sebastians Version ist es besser, die
Herstellung nach draußen zu verlegen.
SEBASTIAN: "Sicher ist sicher. Wir verwenden nämlich Gas, Stickstoff.
Der sorgt dafür, dass aus unserem Frischkäse das doppelte Volumen erzeugt wird."
Na dann: Pump it up, Sebastian!
Das Ziel: Billiger Discounter-Frischkäse
soll nicht nur gestreckt werden,
sondern auch fluffig schmecken.
Dazu erstmal alles mit Molke verdünnen.
Als Abfallprodukt ist die super billig!
Dann fährt Sebastian mal wieder
schwere Geschütze auf.
Ein Propeller am Bohrer soll Stickstoff unter den Frischkäse pumpen und ihn schön fluffig machen.
SEBASTIAN: "Volumen ist schon mal
richtig gekommen."
HILDE: "Ja, ist schon mehr geworden."
SEBASTIAN: "Aber er ist noch einen Ticken zu flüssig."
Zu flüssig - das ist das Stichwort
für die Gelatine.
SEBASTIAN: "Die Gelatine ist halt der kleine Zaubermeister bei dem Trick."
Sie bindet den Frischkäse und hält
so das neue Volumen zusammen.
Aus flüssig mach fluffig!
SEBASTIAN: "Aus dem Discounter-Frischkäse haben wir
die doppelte Menge Frischkäsezubereitung erzeugt.
Das könnten wir jetzt in den Markt bringen
als luftig lockere Käsecreme.
Der Wolkengenuss, der dir morgens
den Kuss auf die Wange gibt"
HILDE: "Das hast du aber schön gedichtet!" - "Ja, oder?"
Ein Gedicht! Auch für die Hersteller.
Sie verkaufen die luftigen Produkte mit
Gelatine im Schnitt sogar fast 60
Prozent teurer als normalen Frischkäse.
Das ist ganz nach Sebastians Geschmack.
Hat nur leider mit richtigem Frischkäse
nicht mehr viel zu tun - und darf sich
daher auch nicht so nennen.
Laut Käseverordnung ist das nur noch eine Frischkäsezubereitung.
Denn es stecken bis zu 30 Prozent andere Zutaten mit drin.
So viel heiße Luft muss man doch schmecken!
Im Test tritt Sebastians
Frischkäsezubereitung auf der grünen
Serviette gegen den echten Frischkäse
von Hilde auf der roten an.
Was sagen unsere Tester?
TESTERIN 1: "Der Rote ist sehr cremig und auch echt gut,
aber der grüne ist cremig und hat so einen bestimmten Geschmack.
Ich würde jetzt nicht genau sagen, was für einen,
aber er schmeckt mir besser."
TESTERIN 2: "Der Grüne schmeckt mir besser."
TESTERIN 3: "Der Grüne ist wesentlich besser. Cremiger."
TESTERIN 4: "Mir schmeckt der Käse auf dem grünen Brett besser."
TESTERIN 5: "Grün schmeckt mir sehr viel besser als rot."
TESTERIN 6: "Der Grüne hat mir besser geschmeckt."
TESTERIN 7: "Mein Favorit ist auch der Grüne."
Für unsere Tester ist die Sache klar.
Aber wahre Käseexperten erkennen
doch wohl den Unterschied?
EXPERTIN: "Grün schmeckt mir besser."
"Der ist geschmackvoller, cremiger.
Meiner Meinung nach."
EXPERTE: "Ich würde den Grünen vorziehen."
Oder auch nicht...
Das Endergebnis: 13 zu 2 Stimmen für
Sebastians gestreckte Frischkäsezubereitung.
SEBASTIAN: "Da kann man mal wieder sehen wie die
Industrie den Geschmack der Gesellschaft erzieht."
"Echten Frischkäse kennt kaum
einer. Die Frischkäsezubereitung mit
"Gelatine, Verdickungsmittel, bisschen Molke... das schmeckt den Leuten."
"Schön cremig, abgebunden."
"Wer echten Frischkäse möchte,
schaut einfach mal auf die Zutatenliste."
Übrigens: Gelatine kommt
selbst bei Fruchtsäften zum Einsatz.
Damit werden Trübstoffe herausgefiltert.
Wenn du also auf Gelatine in deinem
Saft verzichten willst, solltest du auf
das "vegan"-Siegel achten.
Neue Tricks, Checks und Duelle der
ZDFbesseresser gibt es
jeden Dienstag und Donnerstag auf unserem Kanal.
Ihr wollt nichts verpassen?
Dann aktiviert die Glocke neben eurem
Abonnier-Button!